yeah thank you thank you for coming
um we at Alchemy are using a Time series
databases in fact we noticed a couple of
months ago that we need something like
that and we went through a bit of a
process to see what technology we should
use how to deploy it and a couple of
like General decisions were in there
that I would like to talk about
so um I hope that from this talk
um you will go away like with knowledge
about what time series data and
databases are like if you don't know
already but also with a bit of um
yeah some some different angles maybe on
how to look at these kind of databases
if you would like to use them
so
um yeah
I found this uh this website DB
engines.com that tracks the popularity
of the database systems
um and apparently in the last 10 years
the popularity of Time series databases
has been rising which is also a great
occasion to give the talk about that
second only to graph databases but
really what I want to introduce with
this plot is what time series data is
and time series data is really any kind
of data that is like indexed graphed by
sorted by time and so whenever you see
that time is on the x-axis then it's
time series data and that's yeah that's
that's quite Broad
um and as you would expect it's really
everywhere like weather songs
um traffic it's it's everywhere where
you take data in a sequential way
um and so you have probably worked with
it
and now continue into what a Time series
database is
well it's a database of course you got
that from the name but then it is
basically only optimized for time series
data so the strong ordering of date
um yeah Day times gives you the ability
or or enables the ability to
um yeah do better indexing and thus
better compression and Achieve higher
rights and query speeds
right
um so this this is already everything
like about what time series data and the
time series databases are
um now I want to switch gears a little
bit and go into what we at ultimate do
and why we have the need for a Time
series database and for that I have to
talk a little bit about concrete so
concrete is what you get when you mix
cement in the upper right with sand and
water and then it first looks like in
the upper left picture so a little
flubbery mass and then it hardens and I
mean look around you it is basically
everywhere there's a pretty cool video
by veritasium that just came out last
Friday
um yeah I liked it go ahead and watch it
um and yeah it's I mean it's in a way if
you think about it it's quite awesome we
can build massive objects with it uh
Bridges Twisted Towers yeah of course
it's awesome but as you're guessing
there must be a catch and the catch in
this case is that
cement the production of cement which
you really need produces eight percent
of greenhouse gases that humans produce
so this is quite a lot and as you also
know greenhouse gases
well heat the atmosphere Bowl yours ice
caps give us penguin soup like forest
fires and flooding and that's all things
it kills life and we don't want that so
what can we do about it
and actually there is there is something
we can do about it
um and already today it's possible to
make the same amount of concrete with
just half the amount of cement which
would like right off the bat
um slash the amount of greenhouse gases
that are emitted of that because it's
like this eight percent is just from
cement it's not from the transport or
anything else
why is nobody doing that well as so
often when things get complicated and in
this case or difficult there are two
ways to do it at least here you could
you could do it with more Workforce
because you have to very precisely steer
your recipes
um but it turns out you can also do that
with process control and this is what we
do at Alchemy so in order to exercise
process control
um we need process data and this is what
you see by the dotted lines like on the
left side we take data from the plant we
also take data from these concrete
mixers on the road and sometime in the
future we will also take some data from
um yeah the construction sites like from
these pumps that bring the concrete then
to their final position in the building
now
um
that is like all of the data we collect
basically is time series beta data but
that doesn't mean that we need a Time
same time series database for all of the
data especially the data from the plant
for example is nested there are many
relations so we we use a relational
database for that but if we look at the
data that comes from the concrete mixing
trucks
um this data is actually very
homogeneous and there's lots of it so
let's have a look at the concrete mixing
trucks
um there are like three sensors that we
have first and foremost in the middle is
the oil pressure sensor
um that is the most important we'll get
to that there's a sensor that measures
the drum rotation
because like if it's if it's going One
Direction it's pulling and pulling in
the concrete and mixing it the other
rotation is basically unloading it we
track the addition of water because
that's forbidden and there's a Telemetry
device that collects all the data from
the sensors and sends it to us
this is what the data looks like so it's
all time series data and let's look at
the bottom first so we have an indicator
of if the truck is standing or moving so
in the beginning it's it's standing in
this case so this is this is all one
delivery I should say so in the
beginning it's just sending and and
chilling at the plant then it's driving
through the construction site and then
it's at the construction site and later
um yeah driving home in the middle we
have the drum rotation and there's like
um if it's positive it means that the
drum is rotating inwards it's pulling in
the concrete and yeah you see what it
does there and then in the middle of
that construction site bit it's negative
and that means this is where it's
unloading oops sorry and then we have
the oil pressure so the oil pressure
curve is interesting because there you
see you see that it's loaded in three in
four or five batches
which like the oil pressure increases
then in the beginning there in the plant
and then you have some time on the road
and I don't know if you can no you can't
see my mouse but
um what you see is that at this last bit
of the at the construction site where
it's waiting there the oil pressure is
essentially Rising a little bit and this
is like this is really really
interesting to concrete technologists
because this is a data point that that
they don't usually get they usually have
laboratory data on the concrete and now
they have like real life data and they
have so many more data points than
before and that helps them to optimize
the recipes and to adapt them and drive
down the amount of cement per cubic
meter of concrete so this is this is
where the business value lies
essentially
right back to Tech or back to back to
say what we do with the data and why we
need a Time series database so at this
point where the line is we basically
know hey because the truck is sending
data continuously right it's just when
you look at the truck only we don't know
basically where like where it's going
what delivery it's doing but at that
point we we get data from the plant as
well that tells us okay we have to map
that truck to this delivery
um but unfortunately we have to go back
for half an hour because we need this
data in the beginning especially for the
oil pressure to do some normalization
and that means we we if you think about
the data system we can't just have a
system that that flows the data
somewhere but we need some sort of
buffer
um and then what we do is to like every
five minutes odds we go and
essentially load everything that we
think belongs to the delivery and put
that on the main database Hub delivery
so this is this is a case where we have
to query windows and time again and
again and again and this is something
that time series database is really good
at some more consideration so it's it's
also a lot of data like one track gives
you 30 megabytes a day like at the
moment there are around 60 trucks
driving which are equipped and somewhere
and yet next year will will hit the 1000
a thousand trucks Mark hopefully so
that'll be 30 gigabytes a day which you
know it's not it's not Facebook or
Google level but it's also something you
don't want to be doing on your laptop
and of course
um it has to be integrated to our system
so there are multiple dependent apps as
I said before it's time series data and
and all or yeah no really all of the
apps um query windows in time so so we
really want to have that boost from a
Time series database
now
um
when we when we realized that we have
this use case we essentially had three
people who uh wanted to look in parallel
into these and wanted to do spikes on
different ways of doing that so meet
Alice Bob and Chris
um not their real names and they they
looked into self-hosted dedicated time
series database because there's a lot of
Technology out there and it's it's kind
of interesting to to see if there's a
very specialized product that would do
this best Bob wanted to see if we could
adapt manage progress because postgres
is what our team is using all of the
time and everybody knows it so there's
there's something there that is
important as well
um and then Chris wanted to see if yeah
what what the fully managed options are
because we act we're hoping I guess I
showed you before we hope that the
business is scaling a lot in the future
and the fully managed option would
probably be the best one for that so
let's start with self-hosted dedicated
Time series
there are lots of Technologies out there
um
for and and lots of them are integrated
with some one or the other tool already
for example graphite is the database
that's behind
um grafana and then also one comment
here there are there are relational
there are databases that are based on
the relational database for example time
scale which is based on postgres but
there are other ones as well
um now
Alice looked into influx PB because it's
the most popular one
um and it's also available as a managed
service on AWS has python bindings
um and it's yeah it's quite easy easily
installed and easy to be used however it
does have a custom query language so
that's something to keep in mind but it
yeah it's it it goes down to the layer
where it returns a pandas data frame
which of course is Handy
however then LS went to talk to our
devops guy or yeah our defense Guy and
um
it turns out that for yeah for for death
of self-hosting critical infrastructure
is probably not the best thing to do
first of all you need
um a number of people who know the
technology especially also with the
custom query language it's better to
have more than one person on board
um and then there is there is some
considerable devops capacity Bound by
something like that we do have one
service that we self-host and it has
been down a couple of times so we have
experience with self-hosting in a way
and it it is in it difficult to
guarantee High uptime
so uh yeah that's that's the story for
uh self-hosting next up we have Bob
looking into manage postgres
and Bob found this intriguing
article on how to improve the
performance of postgres for time series
data and it like I think it looks quite
spectacular in Blue on the left side you
have the the performance of vanilla
postgres and the performance of course
goes down with a number of records and
then after these performance tweaks
um the the performance stays at a very
very high level and so what they did in
this article is it's like on the right
side you can see there's on the leftmost
bar is the original postgres they have
some optimized data types which I think
isn't really worth mentioning they use a
block range index then which is
optimized for time series data so that's
that's something you can do but yeah you
see the name of the game is partitioning
um and partitioning is something yeah
I'll get a little bit more into that but
this is something you have to do
yourself now Bob was pretty excited
um and the yeah as I said before the
really cool thing about this is that we
only use existing Tech we we use
postgresql and SQL Alchemy heavily in
our company and we can do everything
with that if we went down this road
however
um as I said before partitioning is the
name of the game and like what
partitioning means is that you
essentially take a table and make
multiple tables from it along one or
even along multiple variables
um so if you do that by time for example
you could say you do one table for each
day however yeah that that wouldn't
really help us as we would be writing
always on the same petition as the data
comes in live
and also for query performance it
wouldn't really help us because we query
like most of the time we also we just
want to query the recent the most recent
data and so yeah we didn't really want
to go with
partitioning by time or yeah
and then by device ID
that well that that's the other way to
go to to Really split
like the what the workers could do on
the on the data when it's distributed
um again here are some here is some
issue with uh scaling because at some
point it's like in the beginning we
would maybe say we start with five
petitions or ten and then at some point
uh we would say okay now we need 50 or
100 petitions and when you do that or at
least for us there was no easy way to do
this kind of migration we would have had
to fully migrate uh the database and so
what
Bob and death of guy realizes that there
is some upfront decision making decision
making Necessary and we don't know if it
actually works
um with scaling until we have seen it
and so this is something to keep in mind
with this approach
um yeah now uh Chris went for the fully
managed here there are some yeah the
options the two options because we are
on AWS that we had is in flexdb and AWS
time stream and fully managed in this
sense means means like if you think of
S3 you don't you don't partition any
disk or something or you don't you don't
um yeah provision a disk or workers that
would store it or write the data for you
you really say I want the bucket and in
this case you would say I want a
database and a table and that's really
all to all you do to set up the system
and similarly you have granularly
billing so so your your billing is you
write you you pay for every right for
all the data you have there and you also
pay for the querying
and of course so Claire looked into this
um but of course the question is then
can we can we actually pay for this this
is this was the main question
um they had so more or less the first
thing they did is
make an extra table and see if we yeah
how much how much data it is how much
the writing storing querying will cost
um and what we uh saw is well this is
this is just a number that came out
there uh but what we saw is that
we can project this cost like it's it's
going to become it's not going to be
cheaper over the time that we use it
however it it does we know that it does
fit your federal budget and there's no
further devops required in its case
automatically
um spoiler alert we yeah we continued
with with using a Time stream and we
measure the cost of time stream now it's
somewhat difficult to measure because
the number of truck is rising all of the
time and it's um yeah like sometimes
they're on holiday and stuff like that
and there's yeah there's more
optimization of the cost necessary if we
think we should do that
and of course the Fab word of warning
here the same their service of course
scaled seamlessly and so does the cost
um right and so
everybody reconvened and looked at the
options
and so this is this is basically the
final categories that we had so we
wanted something that is python
integrated
um or at least where the team doesn't
have to learn too much manage postgres
of course would be the the best option
for python integration then also for new
no new tech because both other options
have new technology included but then
for how easy the devops is and the
scaling the fully managed solution and
that is time stream definitely wins out
the others
operating cost is highest we think for
time screen we didn't really check the
others but as I said before like this is
we we projected that it works for us and
so that's what we went with
um a few words on the implementation now
so this is what it looks like
um and yeah as you can see it's it's a
relatively
small diagram from the drugs trucks that
goes into
S3 first and then with the Lambda
function to SNS in the future hopefully
directly to SNS and it's then it goes
into Kinesis because it doesn't stay
forever in time stream and this is like
in German we would say end lager I guess
and what really what we use for all of
the day-to-day work is then time stream
into which it is posted with a Lambda
function and then we have all these apps
on the right side that query the data
from timestamp
um quickly wanted to show how to write
with the Lambda function and a few of
the apps
so this is the code of the Lambda
function on the left side you basically
see the the function that's called Fast
there
um yeah there there are there's of
course some transformation of the data
necessary that I don't show here and
then on the right this is how you write
to python so to to time stream and this
is all python there is no what like
there is no um
a special dialect needed
and this is one of the actual query set
we we use and here you can see that for
querying you still need a language
different than python this is so they
have an SQL dialect which incidentally
this is a good thing because many of our
developers already know SQL
um and there's a tool the AWS data
Wrangler that Returns the pandas data
fan which which makes it really really
convenient
um right and yeah that's that's that's
really all the code that I'm showing
um there are a few apps like that this
this is a very simple app that we built
with property dash for debugging
um it uses a query similar to the one
that I showed you before and that's just
a very Nimble project
um uh yeah written in little time a
couple of hundred lines and that's it
there's the app for the mechanics who
install the sensors which is also cool
because they they essentially install
the sensors and then see can can check
right away if what they installed there
works and then you can also directly
query it from grafana which is important
for us to see that all of the data I
know from all of the tracks comes in as
we wish
right
um so yeah that brings me to the end of
my talk
um
yeah I saw a
as I hope I could have shown like time
series data is something that's
everywhere and maybe you have a need for
a Time series uh database we looked into
a couple of options for time series
databases and basically more like
General approaches to how to solve these
um self-hosting adapting managed
postgres and the fully managed option
the categories that helped us evaluating
is how well how good is the python
integration or how like is there python
integration
um we wanted to have as as little new
tech as possible
um easy devops easy scaling and yeah the
operating cost is of course the question
as well
and I would also like to say that we are
actually where we're hiring if you want
to join us for our journey in reducing
the carbon emissions of cement
um then yeah please talk to us on the
Discord Channel currently we only have a
position album for a junior
so a junior position but there's more
many many positions to come soon so uh
please check out our career page
thank you
thank you for your presentation
I have seen many people taking pictures
here and I want to encourage you to
share your pre Impressions on all social
media like tweeting with the hashtag
pycon de or hashtag Pi data Berlin
and now we have some few questions
the first question came in very early
and is why is there a drum rotation even
after unloading the concrete in the
construction site yeah
um well they simply return inwards so
that they don't lose anything
and and also if you if you so you want
to keep it rotating so it doesn't stay
so it doesn't so the rotation
essentially the movement keeps it from
hardening
you got simplifier yeah
next question is what is different in a
typical time series DB in comparison to
normal relation DBS
um
well as I said in the beginning the the
really the big difference and I only
said that in a nutshell and I'm I'm
probably not the expert to answer
detailed questions on that but really
the question it's a question of
optimization when you know that you have
when you know that you have
um
like flat data structures that are like
equally spaced in time that that would
be ideal
um then you that yeah that just allows
you to do very efficient indexing
yeah but I can't add more than I had on
the slides I'm sorry about that
next question is can you elaborate a bit
on time series databases with a
multi-dimensional database why should
one choose one over the other
[Music]
um
sorry I don't know what a
multi-dimensional database is
so then we will go to the next question
have you considered having flat file
database with a custom backend for
queries yeah that's actually what we did
in the beginning we had
um we had five CSV files essentially on
S3 but it turns out they're not very
flexible
um in the end and and also very costly
because you have to you have to read
them all of the time right
um and yeah at some point that becomes a
big big bottleneck especially for
scaling yeah
next question is do you think you may
outground time stream both in terms of
business requirements and size of the
data set
I don't think so
um it's
well I I haven't I haven't read a
maximum number of like what the what the
data is that it can well like what the
amount of data is that it can hold but
basically it is it's
um yeah it scales
yeah so it it does it does a lot like
the partitioning that I mentioned before
is done automatically by time stream and
there's many it it partitions along many
dimensions so it's really really
optimized for large large-scale data so
I don't think that it will ever that our
case will ever outgrow time stream yeah
I have two questions now which are
pretty similar first one is what is the
frequency of input data and second how
do you decide how often you send the
data from the drugs you mentioned it's
done every five minutes I think first
one is yeah no no um yeah so every
basically this Telemetry box on the
truck sends us a Json blob every 10
seconds
and that's for every truck
um so this is and the and this is
roughly nine kilobytes
um the size of the payload essentially
that we get
um and then every five minutes is we
read the data from time stream to then
assorted to our main database which
which is what serves our product
so this is the five minutes is a step
within our application
next question is since you also
mentioned time scale and like SQL a lot
would you fully manage time scale take
all your boxes
um good question
um
yeah could be could be very interesting
like I we haven't we haven't tried to
understand if we if you could use time
stream with
um with SQL Alchemy because we're heavy
users of SQL Alchemy that pythonizes
everything and then and then if yes
probably yes
next question is what are the
differences between the different types
of TS DB for example influx DB versus
graphite
um
can't really say can't really say yeah I
assume there are really tailored to the
Frameworks that are built around them
last question is do I get it right that
you have to code your entire model into
the pipe object
I don't understand the question sorry so
should I repeat it yeah yeah maybe do I
get it right that you have to code your
entire model into the pipe object
well no you don't get that right
that's not what we did
last but not least are you uploading
your slides somewhere
that's a question to you actually
um I think the slides will be updated
uploaded in the schedule
but I think I can just ask for that sure
yeah happy to do so yeah thank you for
your
presentation I think the people
appreciate your work for the climate and
our environment
thank you